hello everybody my name is mark balor
and welcome back to hooni pop we
are about to go on another date and
actually succeed at it and don't you
guys forget it
to do that we oh we're all kind of new
jesse and nabia jasobia how are you
doing jasobia
i like jesse i do i like to see a lot i
like obvious too
excuse me hi sorry to bother you but
you're misty cats right
guilty really
no i can't oh my wow i can't believe
i'm meeting the misty cats i have a
youtube channel
i'm your biggest fan i've seen all your
films at least a dozen times
oh thank you sweetie
i'm always happy to meet a fan of my
work what's your favorite film
my favorite uh well lately i've been
watching the one
with you and brandy lux a lot
i remember that one that was a fun shoot
brandi really knows how to work with her
tongue i've done
yeah ah sorry i got a little
lost in thought i'm just just so nervous
there's nothing to be nervous about
sweetie i don't bite
well not unless you asked me to
i wouldn't bite even if you did just
putting it out there
i have a youtube channel i have many
subscribers many people watch
me i don't do that many collabs but i've
been known to work with a few people
here there
how are you doing can i ask you about
something sort of
private are you talking to me now rather
embarrassing oh of course yes do you
have
any techniques for lasting longer
you know it in bed oh
usually i take some melatonin to make my
sleep last
longer really really gets me under you
know sometimes you know
oh like i'm not much for like tylenol pm
or anything like that
uh yeah i have some techniques to fall
asleep very quickly that's that's
probably
right pretty good think about it
uh literally only keggles
nothing but i max out the weights on the
keggle machine
i tried those before unfortunately they
don't really seem to help in my case
perhaps there's something wrong with me
sometimes i feel like i have no control
over myself
all it takes is one big uh
move let's say and it all just
comes out you're being really vague
here you need to be more specific in
details one pump chump a four of a kind
match directed that obviously
interesting hi jesse you know
i've always wanted to ask you something
would you ever consider marrying someone
who's 10 years older than you
died if she was 30 years old what are
you talking
about 30 years so full of [__]
no come on well we are full of [__]
anyway hello
um
boom are you sure yeah they're so nice
they are i don't feel as though i've
earned such a gift
no it's fine and your mere presence
is a gift to all who are around you
nailed it
i'm the best um what have we got there's
got to be a date that can get rid of uh
oh wait actually wait i just saw she ha
ha ha but i gotta be careful how about i
give this over
to you because you're your sentiment
don't
last too long lube you want some
lube all right let's go on that date
sure why not
after all what are vacations for
yeah okay sure yeah vacations are for
double dates
i'm down with that if you're down with
my incredible puzzle skills
horny to be here with you happy uh not
horny
well yes horny but
oh man okay anyway let's let me show you
how the magic of me
works
[Music]
why not hey
yeah really doesn't do much if you don't
have the the passion there right off the
bat it's really going
going downhill quick okay just nice and
easy we're starting off slow
start enough gentle can't rush into
these things
gotta give it time
nope i practice touching every day
oh wait no not you you do this
because you need the stamina okay so now
we gotta start
really making some moves here no
not yet because
you all right okay now we're going to
start making some moves here
oh my god oh my god
yep feel free to spoil me more i won't
you you don't have any sentiment boom
keep going uh you yes you
what a guy what a guy what what guy
what guy what a guy what a guy
what a guy he's a cannibal version of
whataburger
ooh i smell a combo
boom you need to get stamina
what is oh i forgot about the lube okay
i forget about the whoop
all these are in the wrong spots what is
that all doing um
damn i should have saved the sentiment
then uh damn i can't really do anything
about that okay
uh damn okay kind of work myself into a
corner here
all right then we're just gonna have to
do something
a little unorthodox and by unorthodox i
mean
absolutely perfectly normal hey look at
that
that worked out well i didn't even plan
for that hell yeah
okay we need the lube we gotta get lube
somehow in here
okay you're gonna get lube lube lube
time what does this do
lube be patient
be patient with what depression with lot
yeah whatever
lube is lubed lube is
lube okay lube is lubed so now we just
need to
figure out a way to yeah i can kind of
get this
going for the passion to be down there
and the passion over here
here no no too tired no no the stamina
is really running into a problem here
why is this stamina so disparate i mean
i guess
and then i can do some stamina now we
can do the passion
and that's okay because you just got
stamina
this will help no you don't like that
but you need to do this because you
don't have it we need
the stamina is a problem okay you got
that there you can get this
here oh my god is that what i think it
is
holy crap what would that even do five
stamina oh and i can't even do it
because i
oh how am i gonna even how would i even
set that up
oh but that's such a good move oh but
how do i set it up i know
if i if oh oh okay what if i do this
this is a technically a two stamina move
which kind of sucks but whatever keeps
going
the stamina ma'am what happens if i do
this it brings
it doesn't bring any of them i wouldn't
be able to stamina
immediately afterwards oh
oh god damn it damn it
damn you the hell okay
i might be able to fix it because
there's reds over here so if i figure
out a way to get the red
either down one or up one god damn it
that was so
beautiful it was beautiful
god damn it okay so if i if i go here
and do
that that wouldn't put a red where i
need it to be but it
might help put a red where it needs to
be
later did it
no all right fine
oh you suck okay what happens if i do
this
it's not great i'm gonna be chasing this
freaking red
okay buddy this would get it there okay
because then i get a move back and then
you do the passion
or what the that isn't
that was not even that great i don't
know why i was so obsessed with that
okay whatever but i did that and that
felt good and at the end of the day when
you're on a date that's what it's all
about so shut up and stop judging me
i'm judging you and you're all judging
each other so judge each other in the
comments and leave me
out of it i don't want any part of it
okay for now i'm just gonna do small fry
moves i'll be fine
give her some stamina back okay cool
we're back in business
there we go oh but you don't like uh
neither of them lighting it doesn't
matter
sorry uh it's fine
whatever happened i'm not gonna question
it and everything's just very all
over the place it's not great setups
because i wasted it all trying to get
that one
red blast to go out and if i don't play
my cards right here i
am gonna lose this i might lose this
okay obvious out of the way first move
extra move is always good and then less
obvious out of the way
next with this just
good passion you like passion 15 that's
it god damn
[__] i need to get a hundred and eight
and six moves god damn it it always
happens like this
oh you even like i know you like
yeah i might as well give uh you full
passion because there's a setup here for
this
oh my god okay that's a good start we
got four moves left
i don't know how many more like combos
i'm gonna get
out of this but it's something i could
do this
and get some stamina combo but what else
would it really do
no not even a little bit i could do this
get the sentiment
get the extra moves because there's a
lot of
yes worth it yes
we're in business baby we're in business
we're in business uh there's potential
for more moves here
but i think i'm actually in the clear
i'm pretty sure that if i just
blam it's 15 there i'm pretty sure i'm
in the clear
but it's got extra movement i think i'm
good
we're close anyway
that is hot yes yes i'm a god
i'm a sex god i'm a puzzle god because
of the sex god it's unrelated
ah i feel like it's been years since i
had that much fun
i know all of our dates in the past few
weeks have been horrible
i meant to ask you earlier what brings
you in a de poona
misty guest star at the strip club or
are you doing a tropical shoot actually
i'm just here on vacation i needed to
get away from it all for a while yeah
truth is
they don't really call me anymore i
guess that's
the industry though once you hit a
certain age
nobody wants you anymore what
how can that be look at you you're
stunning you're beautiful you're
perfect thank you sweetie
you know you're pretty cute yourself
[Music]
i said something here
there's something going on oh but
there's attracted and
horny over here excuse me ladies
my spidey sense is dangling my attracted
and horny senses
tingling in the gift shop you sort
whatever this is out
i'll see you later
hey if either you guys want to party i
can get you some good [__]
hey how's it going hey listen um
i'm going to give you some
[Music]
yeah whatever you're not a masseuse i
get it uh oh
that's a pretty good one the goldfish
plush is good who likes romance
appreciate it
you like romance you and this one sucks
get this out of here consume
consume my ass oh let's talk last night
this
man at work said i remind him of a blow
up doll
with nothing in my head wow i didn't
think that was a very nice thing to say
to me
it was can you believe that i can't
believe that
you know you're wrong that's horrible
it's just awful
it ain't right nice to a lady yeah
i don't like it none too much when
people are mean like that yeah me
neither
reason for it no reason nice
hyper sensitive no come on becomes upset
she'll drain 30
passion for both herself and her date
wow that's quite the suck
hey don't take this in a bad way or
nothing but you seem kind of like
normal you know oh i kind of wonder like
you grew up your parents must still be
together yeah
oh no no no i know they got divorced
oh [__] sorry to bring it up but hey at
least you still got a dad
it was just me my mom and my brothers
that is so
perfect
uh well actually or yeah i don't know
how to bring this up oh
anyway let's see if we can get another
gift uh
anal beads who would want anal
[Music]
beads
one of you likes romance i know one of
you likes romance nora
nora is this laced with something no
it's good yeah [__] good who's an
old-fashioned girl you're not an
old-fashioned girl
what's with the gifts huh did you get
your own self to worry about
hey whoa watch it okay whatever all
right so it was abandonment issues
anytime your focus is turned away from
nora she'll drain five percent of the
current earned affection for the date oh
my god are you
kidding me that's horrible what no what
that's horrible okay uh stamina nah
let's get something that's gonna help
with um
down the road stuff okay might as well
do the bunny plush because that's not
bad drains all purchase and passion gets
one percent older oh
oh oh you oh
that's good oh that's that's good okay
we'll do that
okay you're in charge of broken hearts
you're in charge of passion
okay that's good actually that is very
good let's go
together i want to play too you play you
play
listen we're all attracted we're all
horny
let's go into the puzzle or the secret
grotto what the
[__] is a secret grotto the only pool in
the resort people ain't [__] peeing
in all day
okay so if i take my attention away
she'll drain five percent that means i
gotta be real careful
about who i'm talking to i gotta be real
careful okay okay
okay let's start off sentiment over here
we gotta build you
up with the
uh frick how do i get you
ah i don't need to watch this
well that took care of that anyway you
like i feel you
i feel you later wink
wink well i just ruined all my chances
but whatever um okay
uh you uh sentiment you want that
and moves are good so let's
wait on that okay this
good uh if we move
oh no that's oh no it's it's fine there
there's already a blue set up here but
she doesn't have enough stamina for that
so that's kind of a problem
uh oh actually oh if i need stamina this
is kind of a
desperate move but you know i'm not too
upset about it
because then i can do this and that
saves me it's gonna be nice to me now
maybe hold on hold your horses
cause i'm gonna do this i'm complaining
you shouldn't be you should not be
okay whatever oh damn it okay oh
it must be oh it's only a percent of the
current amount okay it's not the total
okay that's better all right so what we
got to do is we got to get your passion
up because we can duplicate
your passion so we just have to focus on
you
it's all about you ma'am
ma'am and it's less about nora
nor i'm ignoring you it's funny that
your name is
ignora ignore the explorer over there
okay passion passion is good passion's
good
we like passion we love the passion kind
of haphazard on the
actual things that can be done but
that's not bad
okay so i'm turning my attention away
it'll be all right nora adios
we're gonna win this with passion that's
how we're going to do this
combo combo
wombo combo is a thing of beauty
bam yay indeed
okay i need you to have the passion
which
means that i need to drop this down
one now this goes across
okay passion has been built up pretty
good
that's not bad passion i could duplicate
it now and toss it across
or i could get a little more out of it i
guess there's a nice intersection of uh
blues here but it's gonna get ruined as
soon as i smash this down
that could work
um speaking of smash let's smash your
passion across you're welcome but i
didn't do it for you
oh wait you have them oh that's a good
one i can't pass it up
more stan this is all you
bam okay now i'm leaving
goodbye okay i'm back hey nora hey
sorry for ignoring ya uh i just wanted
to say how
pretty your eyes are in the moonlight i
never noticed the way your
smile lights up a room your pointy
shoulders are
really something special along with your
pointy chin everything about you is
pointy
anyway uh you don't need sentiment well
actually that might not be bad because
you do
love romance i know that kind of running
into a bit of an issue here but i can i
can definitely
get the sentiment required i just don't
know if it'd be the best
because i can convert this right now
then i'd have to switch
because not worth it this is nice
this is nice i know
all right but i gotta go uh just hold on
it'll be fine i'm gonna just
jet over there and i'll be right back oh
man this would be good if i had some
semblance of
literally anything but okay whatever
it's fine
because this is what i'm going for bam
there yay
and then exhaustion okay whatever i'm
going back because i'm going to do
this i'm doing this
and then i'm doing oh a little bit of
this i'm complaining yeah well you do
you don't complain because it only gets
better from here because watch
out for i don't know what am i doing
i know what i'm doing i know exactly
what i'm doing i'm running out of moves
oh my god i was doing so good
what the hell when did i start running
out of moves
when in the hell what the dick the dick
oh [__] what just happened
i had everything everything was good
what the hell just happened
okay wait no i see the move i see it
you see the move you see what i'm going
for this is gonna win it
watch this you watching good don't blink
you'll miss it
god those power blocks really give them
giving give them give them give them
give them give them give them give them
give them
a gummy come and give me give me give me
give me give me give me thank you oh
shoot i haven't got my jammies all away
oh me too that ain't the only thing
that's wet around here yeah i peed my
pants long time ago
wait what's wrong with your lips oh god
i forgot that this is part of it
i'll censor it oh god censor it center
it out i i'm doing poorly anyway censor
it all out it's fine
we don't need to worry about it none uh
don't worry uh this is
oh
don't look everybody hide your shame you
should be ashamed of yourself
hide it think we made a big
mess in the water how did that happen
it's water
i'm definitely gonna have to add some
extra chlorine in there
what did you two do you poop in the
water
did you both poop in the water hello
attracted
and horny excuse me ladies
i've solved your puzzle in taking your
fruit i shall go on my way now
good morning sugar tits morning morning
hello how are you good to see you i have
gifts
probably i'm thinking i do what do you
guys like uh you like star you like
red there's two flirtations of boozies
that's good
okay that's good for you here ch chug
chug a log
chugga luga chugga gold that my post
works
chug chug chug chug a log
chug chug
[Applause]
yes hey you want a hot dog
you want a hot dog that's pretty good
big blush
yes would you like muscles
would you like some monsters monsters
well i didn't hear anything you said
what were you saying
into watching girls eat are you well
guess what yes i
am here stuff your face at least you
know how to make yourself useful
yep i'm a hamburger man uh i don't even
want to talk to you guys
we're going on a date right now to go
out with two lookers like you
never we'd never you would never
never you would never go or never miss a
chance i couldn't exactly tell which one
was it
oh this is lovely i love the aquarium
an aquarium all right i
hope you know what you're doing what do
you mean what i'm doing what do you
expect me to do at an aquarium
what do you think is going to happen at
the aquarium nothing i hope
anyway all right let's get this show on
the road uh
paulie oh god apparently that's
too advanced for you let's just get the
free moves out of the way is this still
gonna
that's still gonna exhaust you wow okay
um all right let's get the
what was your commitment issues yeah
let's get the
passion up blam okay now we got this
good heavens great heavens is what
everyone says when they're done with me
back to you
okay good love that was good love i like
that love that was great love
i really need to get stamina i really
can't go into these with like
low stamina i keep doing that because i
keep loading them up with hot dogs and
hamburgers and
that really drains their stamina long
term they really can't sustain that
momentum
and momentum is everything in a date if
you stop moving you stop
dating how the hell am i going to get
the stamina here what am i
doing oh yeah
this will do yeah okay and then this
will fill you right up
like a hot dog or a hamburger stuffed
pre-aquarium date and then there's a
perfect
setup you're going to do something else
you want some of this
no not a bad at all actually moves
please
thank you i am a god i am a god of this
you get easy peasy because it squeezes
me
this one
i am getting so goddamn good but we need
to get the passion up the passion is
nowhere near the level that it needs to
be
i need the passion gushing it's got a
gush
passion what do you have hmm
what is that gonna do is that even worth
it yeah whatever let's do it sweet deal
sweet deal because it gave
those how are we still low on
we're still low on whatever i was gonna
stamina
oh my oh me
okay good good good this is going swell
it's going super swell
oh thanks you're welcome
i literally don't remember what i just
gave you
but i was thinking of you or something
more passion i guess
god damn we are loaded up to the tits
with passion
which is great but at the same time
haven't been getting many actual points
man i cannot get any moons to line up
with this thing
there's nothing that's lining up i could
just piss ashley off right now
and it would clear a lot of the board
and i think i'd be okay
are you serious yeah i think i'm okay
because what i'm gonna do is
make some strategies here
and also set up for a little better
stamina i'm just so much sentiment i
don't need this much sentiment what am i
going to do with the sentiment
i'm not i'm still not building anything
in terms of these
oh you know what screw it i'm just gonna
do it i would have rather had that be
something a bit more special but it just
wasn't giving me anything there's really
not much
god damn great to keep [__] together
okay no promises because what is even
happening with this
goddamn puzzle
i never [__] here and then
now we can do this
that was pretty good we only got seven
moves left oh i need to save this red
for her because without that
it's gonna get dicey but what else am i
gonna do
this has been actually kind of dick and
not even the good
kind do i have any other moves that i
can make i don't
actually i don't so i have to do this
even this is not hers
[Music]
so much sentiment so many hearts very
few
actual point makers why dangerous
territory
god damn it sucks this blows
god damn it you don't like it's moon
this sucks
i don't think i'm gonna make it oh
oh my god i it's maybe
okay okay okay okay okay okay
hey hey
you know there's nowhere else in this
turn that camera back on
i've got a video idea
me too ashley i call it try not
to laugh episode 29. try not to smile
try not to smile episode 29
okay let's see put this here put this
here put that there
put i put this here i spin this around
i crank this shaft and then i turn this
flange
and then i put my left foot in left foot
out spin it all around
now that's a video i will not be posting
to my channel
well oh come on more content for me
guaranteed viral hit right
there that's the content that you're
watching
anyway congratulations each and every
one of you we really pulled together and
we made something special here
anyway i gotta go to the tourist plaza
i'll see you around i'll see you around
gals
lots of fun but you know a rolling stone
and all
ah there abya how do you know her name
um uh hi candace i ain't seen you come
by the club for a few days
oh you ain't sick are ya
no it's nothing like that i just have to
save my money
so i can pay my rent this month whenever
i go to the
strip club i have a tendency to uh uh
spend my entire paycheck
[Music]
that's why you're my favoritest customer
in the whole world
what about me well i don't have any
money okay
okay that makes sense
i'll bite your clean off i'll mike tyson
that [__]
you don't even have to pay me you just
give me some fruit that's literally all
i want is fruit
hello i forgot what i was gonna say
so you talk instead all right i
i'm good at talk what ice cream you like
strawberry ice cream because it tastes
like strawberry
that's pretty good that's really good i
feel very much the same way you feel
i do too we all do we all feel the same
it's crazy how much we feel the same
curiosity but hmm do you like to put on
music when you're
with a girl
wow slow jams volume oh i hear the
the moaning in the darkness oh my god
that's so embarrassing well for you
you or me whatever i'm just gonna go buy
a smoothie
who wants romance you like no you don't
like romance uh
what did one of you one of you one of
you i have
something that one of you wants i know i
do don't i
don't i okay whatever let's just go on a
date hey how about that we both have
plenty
we're good to go take me please i will
on the date
on the date yes i will take you on the
date
keep it in your pants javia
is this the pool that everyone was
peeing in
i haven't even gotten in the water yet
i think there's gonna need to be some
additional censoring here because
that that that was that that's a piece
of cloth that you found drifting in the
wind it just happened to slap right
where your nipples and crotch was
that is just a coincidence that that
works i'm not complaining i am not
complaining
by the way is this going to make you
gush your stamina
or your sentiment thank goodness okay
luke
i don't want to hug all your attention
oh i would have given it to canvas
i want to give it to you candace it's
odd that this
you you guys have the exact same amount
of coverage but your bikini is clearly
bigger
let's make this quick let's let's
lightening around this come on lightning
round we got this
i i know how to play this game i know
how this goes i can do this
i can make it happen super fast i can do
this
super good i can do this really good
watch this and then
watch this and then watch this
that's how we do it and we need you to
get sentiment we need sentiment
oh we have sentiment no yes
i am giving her all the attention
literally
all of it oh god but i gotta get you oh
i gotta get you passion first
you have so many complex needs candice
so many complex needs all right abia
it's time
do not gush all your sentiment away
please
okay good thank goodness oh it chooses
the baggage oh it chooses the baggage
oh that's okay okay that's fine you know
what actually i'm just gonna go ahead
and do this because i'm not gonna it's
30 percent it's not
great but it's fine what oh
it is sweet here's some lube and now
collection grows
larger now uh one move for every two
broken hearts that's
good i love that to me it means we move
more that's what it means okay what i'm
gonna do this is gonna be weird but i'm
gonna do this
because i will because i have wait no
but sh
but the but the but the [__] that she
has the
the globe
damn it all right let's keep going
whatever i'm not going to let that stop
me
don't matter
[Music]
my behavior was unjustified yeah well i
wanted to give you
misunderstand i want to give you that
i'm simply not able to accept that gift
at this time i
know i know okay let's just do a simple
one
okay and that should give enough for
that keep going
keep going and you can get your stamina
back
uh-huh we got a lot of red there and 14
moves left which isn't
the best that i would want but it's not
terrible
maybe if she had passion
that is it probably probably good
yeah that was good okay well it was not
the best but it was pretty good
oh the recipient's date of upsetness oh
so i could upset candace and then then
i'd be fine okay so what if i do that
what if i do this to get rid of some
hearts
oh [__] that's right oh god oh no it's
fine
oh god damn it oh my god ah that was
really not worth it man these learning
experiences really kind of suck
i hope that didn't screw me oh man i'm
so far away from the goal now
i don't think there's any way that i can
actually make this happen damn it
thank you oh no there's no way
last ditch move you have no passion left
because it's all gone because i blasted
it out of existence
okay whatever it was learning learning
experience learning experience god damn
it i get distracted by the bikini boobs
and then
you know whatever give me your fruit
failure a failure
i really failed guys i did it we
did it right yeah oh
yeah oh yeah all right i'm going back to
the hotel room all right so that's the
end for this episode
i am a miserable failure and i will
never know love
and that's the conclusion for all of us
today yeah sorry it was really riding on
all of us uh for me to succeed there and
now all of us will never find love and
that's just the way it is so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
bye